so what is that consolidation
[Music]
debt consolidation just means turning a
bunch of debts into one giant debt this
gives you a lower interest rate lower
monthly payment and a simplified payment
plan but here's the problem you actually
end up paying more and staying in debt
longer with these types of loans because
in almost every case the terms get
extended which does mean a smaller
payment but it goes on forever like the
universe or braised Anatomy what season
are they on 42 Oh 15 close enough now
I'm debt free but let's say in an
alternate universe I have $30,000 in
debt okay track with me on these numbers
I have a $10,000 loan at 12% interest
with a two-year term and a $20,000 loan
at 10% interest with a 4-year term my
monthly payment on that first loan is
five thousand seventeen hang on I messed
something a five hundred and seventeen
dollars and my payment on the second
loan is five five eighty three that's a
total payment of $1,100 a month now
let's say I'm on facebook checking out
the latest memes and I see an ad for a
debt consolidation company they're
promising to lower my payment to just
six hundred and forty dollars per month
with a nine percent interest rate if
you're doing the map at home that's four
hundred and sixty less per month and a
lower interest rate well color me
intrigued
but alas has the great philosopher Bret
Michaels once sagely articulated every
rose has its thorn it will now take me
six years to pay this off six years
turns out smashmouth was wrong all that
glitters is not in fact gold although
that album did glitter and went gold in
fact it went platinum which by the
standards set by the Recording Industry
Association of America is technically
better than gold all that to say I'll
end up shelling out over forty six
thousand dollars to pay off the new loan
verses about forty thousand to pay off
the original loans which means my lower
payment cost me an extra fifty six
hundred dollars and took an extra two
years to pay off I've got two words for
that
oh just now no this conversation always
comes back to interest rate you see the
rate that comes with a debt
consolidation loan is usually set by the
lender and it depends on your credit
score which we talked about in our last
video my point is the interest rate
isn't even the problem most of the time
after someone consolidates their debt it
grows back faster than Tim Allen's beard
in the Santa Claus
it's not about math it's about mindset
Dave Ramsey says personal finance is 80
percent behavior but only 20 percent had
knowledge so even though your choices
landed you in a big steaming pile of
debt you can work your way out you just
need to see debt differently and get on
a plan my favorite plan is the debt
snowball Dave walks you through it the
Financial Peace University a nine lesson
course that's helped millions of people
get out of debt you can check it out at
FPU com here's the bottom line a better
interest rate or lower payment will
treat the symptoms what the debt
snowball fixes the problem and now you
know
[Music]